there's some breaking news for you this
afternoon a former grammar school pupil
who joined Isis has pleaded guilty to
Preparing acts of terrorism in Syria
despite claiming he'd spent his time
there playing computer games Shabazz
Suleiman has just appeared at the older
Bailey let's join Skye's Sadia Chaudhary
who was inside the court afternoon to
you what happened saja
well the interesting thing about Shabbat
Suleiman is that he's not one of these
lonely types of uh terrorists that we
see who has dropped out of school is
radicalized in their bedrooms this is a
guy who is a former grammar school
student and was about to go and study
international relations at University
now he vanished while on holiday with
his family in turkey and says he was
working with a Turkish charity before
being picked up by Turkish security
forces and being swapped in a
controversial prisoner exchange and
Landing finding himself in Isis
territory in Syria now he says he went
there to try and fight against Bashar
al-assad the Syrian President's forces
he says he was trying to defend
um Syrian people from injustices because
he felt that the International Community
had let them down in in court today we
heard that the prosecution had relied on
a sky news interview that Shabbat
Solomon gave in 2017 as part of their
evidence have a listen to what he told
us then
take responsibility I was with Isis I
was with the terrorist organization I
mean
but I mean I didn't kill anyone I I hope
I didn't
oppress anyone I mean
I mean I did have a question cough and a
military uniform but I didn't
I didn't hit anyone I didn't
oppress anyone if you understand I mean
I was there in with military police were
in a military police like I said I was
in the office you feel a criminal not
honestly no do you feel a terrorist
even though you were part-time
very weird honestly no I mean
terrorists when you think of terrorists
you think someone you know with a mask
and you know with a sword you know
beheading people and terrorizing people
well honestly I I was not I mean I was
just relax hiding in raqqa with Syrian
civilians italyby friends they're from
Italy
playing PlayStation or to go around and
bike rides and
normal life normal life
well he also admitted to carrying a
Kalashnikov rifle and celebrating the
Charlie hebdo attacks he even had a norm
degree Abu Sharma Brittany but today in
court he spoke only to confirm his birth
name Shabazz Suleiman and he pleaded
guilty to Preparing acts of terrorism he
is due to be sentenced next month
many thanks indeed Sadia